well any other time of year children
will be lining up to see santa claus
right about now
but this is a holiday season unlike any
other so old st
nick is getting creative he's finding
out what kids want for christmas through
virtual visits or socially distant
appearances because as mary peterson
tells us
nothing can stop santa from beginning or
bringing in that holiday cheer
by the way this story is kids safe
santa's very happy about that santa am i
on the
nice list four-year-old soma knows
the really important question you made
the nice list
of course you've got to keep it up i'm
so happy
making children happy inspired the new
book we are santa
portraits and profiles showcasing 50
american
santas by denver photographer ron cooper
i would love to give this book to a
child who loves santa
but the first thing the child is going
to say is why are there so many
we represent that these are all santa's
helpers and the real santa claus may be
in the book but we can't tell you which
one he is
do you know which one he is i'm afraid i
can't divulge that information
with santa's helpers clothes really make
the man
and some jolly old saint nicks had jelly
good fun
with their fashion choices like santa
nicholas cardello who is a pirate
or singing cowboy santa joe lagrone
and santa david lewis is a sign of these
coveted times inside a globe so he can
still reach out
and touch kids there is also a mrs claus
susan mesko she runs denver's santa
claus school where santa's learned to
answer
the tough questions if the child says
i'm worried that you know my grandma
just died and i want her to come back
from heaven
santa will go into discussing that with
the child
but then talk to them well grandma was
wonderful what was her favorite cookie
back to happier memories santa was based
on
saint nicholas from 3rd century turkey
who is believed to be
dark-skinned a bit of history santa
james
knuckles shares with kids how do you
answer
when children say but santa you're black
i answer the question by telling whoever
that santa is not black or white
or any other complexion or ethnic group
basically i'm the image of a spirit
i am a black santa
is that all right i think it's cool
tristiana is eight years old did you
know that
you are very smart i have a little
thing in my room it says i
am smart i am beautiful i will believe
in myself
santa isn't the only one giving gifts
ron is giving all the proceeds of the
book
to children's hospital colorado but he
got an unexpected gift of his own
for meeting all those santas holiday
rome
i'm 63. and at 63
are you believing in santa again i
certainly believe in the spirit of santa
claus having done this project
absolutely and what's that spirit good
will
kindness charity the spirit of the
season
when santa kj braithwaite met hadley
dylan and mila
he had a question we had five
baby reindeer this year
oh we thought maybe you could help us
name them do you have any names that you
think would be cute
do you name them after us santa
do you feel like perhaps this is the
most
important year to help these children
through this particular christmas
i think it is one of the most important
years
when so much is in change when so much
is uncertain santa can be certain
and that's one thing they can count on
and the children were very concerned
about santa how are you immune to corn
virus
i'll tell you what we are being very
careful
and it's nothing you need to worry about
because it's going to be okay
we wish you a merry christmas so for
santa believers of all ages take comfort
santa says it's going to be okay
for cbs this morning saturday barry
peterson
denver
merry christmas oh ah merry christmas
song
thank you i needed that so good we all
needed that oh really
kids wrote our letters this week yeah we
emailed them
got the requests there you go we'll give
you got to be creative
excellent